sorting a room know
yep
so general Williams is up top
he's kind of walking down right now I
gave you the names the other people I
got one addition chief Kyle Kyl II
ginawa i NN e ll a he's the fire chief
of West Point he's gonna provide general
Williams will provide an opening
statement and then we'll take about four
or five questions from there that'll be
all the information that we can put out
will be from here the next step after
today will be 24 hours later will be it
will release the name any other
questions somebody took a picture of
Darren yeah Lieutenant General Darryl
Williams headed Oh Darryl Williams Bryan
Heverly aníbal Colonel Brett Venable a
hospital Commander Keller hospital
commander and then finally we have a New
York State Police Troop commander true
path commander PB
so we have to do yeah we have to do the
counseling notification officer goes to
Panthers house talks to the family
No
various different activities
in this whole general vicinity
so they were leaving their merits and
then I'm going to which was out here and
they're going to the actual they called
the lanes it's just a general area
to an exercise the LM TV which is a
basically a five-ton truck it's got a
cab and then a bed with two benches on
either side soft can be described
that's that my name is Chris furrow part
antenna curl I'm the public affairs
officer for West hey stop I can't pucker
okay the bunker and natural
striped shirt
good afternoon
today was a tragic day for the West
Point community in our United States
Army early this morning
a troop vehicle carrying 20 cadets
operated by two soldiers was traveling
to a land navigation training site the
cadets were involved in a standard
training exercise it occurs as a part of
their military training program here at
West Point one cadet is confirmed
deceased as of 10:58 a.m. the other
injured personnel received care at
Keller Army Community Hospital and
various other regional medical
facilities their injuries are not
life-threatening our thoughts and
prayers are with the families of the
deceased and our injury I would like to
commend the exceptional efforts and
professionalism of the first responders
and medical personnel and thank our
great New York State Police and our
mutual aid partners we are working we
are working actively to notify next of
kin and we'll provide more information
from the notification
we'll take a few questions driving the
vehicle
army soul the nature of all the injuries
were yeah so I can give you outlook the
hospital commander give you some sense
of the nature of the minor injuries but
we're not prepared to go into the nature
of the injuries so the injuries range
from facial abrasion to a broken arm but
as the general mentioned they're all
life non-life threatening injuries I'm
not prepared to talk about the sea skate
this time concerns there are too many
cadets in the back of favor I do not
have those concerns how did the accident
actually happen did it go did he swerved
to avoid something any more technical
details on how the accident actually
happened yeah we'll know more about that
between that's the gate this were
investigating it now the investigation
will continue we don't know the details
of how the accident actually no I'm not
prepared to say what was the makeup of
the guide today what year are they yeah
these are cadets that are seen these are
seniors could have seniors at West Point
as we call first rising senior class of
2020
yeah so there are seniors as you know we
train very heavily here at West Point
and the training they do is part of our
normal senior training they've been
doing this for some time now and they
were headed to land navigation training
when they're in the back of the truck
they're being transferred to the
Navigator training site and that's why
the vehicle had the hughster not good
evening
not that far not that far at all it
wasn't like it was ten kilometers away
they were close they were the training
man
is it cup no it is not common for these
vehicles to turn over it's very rough
trade you can see the hills we have here
we want to make sure that our soldiers
and our cadets train in realistic
training environment so this is part of
our realistic training this vehicle was
just the vehicle was transformed yes you
can see by looking around very hilly I
[Music]
think very strong I mean this is the
United States Army were strong we're
strong here at West Point the
communities come together very very
nicely as I talked about the medical
support and all the great professionals
we have here along with our partners as
I mentioned so we responded extremely
quickly I came out early this morning
when I found out and our great partners
in New York were here already attending
to thank you very much
[Music]
can we hear from state troopers on
investigation a little bit
but that type of road was in a dirt road
or asphalt who's a dirt road okay